the crazy [ __ ] is going on right now in
the world I feel like like the Pope I
think the Pope has lost his mind
or he just doesn't want to be the Pope
anymore like this dude is out here
slapping before so this woman
so he's so the Pope's walking by shaking
hands with you know the fans the
Catholic fans or whoever you know I
guess the Pope will you call them fans
or followers I don't know it's like a
fence where you can like actually touch
him oh this Pope is just out here you
know kissing babies and shaking hands
with people so he walks by this woman
and she holds his hand grabs him sort of
and pulls him towards her and he freaks
out he's like you know he's mad not even
freaks out the [ __ ] mad okay
you see the video the Pope is mad he's
like you know he slaps her hand like
[ __ ] don't you grab me and then he like
walks away from her like a real like
crotchety old man now um on both sides
of this okay all right let's start with
the woman so this is the Pope like if
you're a Catholic it's like the Pope and
then above the Pope is basically angels
you know Virgin Mary Jesus whatever you
believe in the Pope is supposed to be
the last stop so I totally get that this
is the Pope and you want to shake his
hand and you want to do more you you
like God mr. Pope it would be like if
you add a Star Wars convention you had a
Star Wars convention and George Lucas is
walking by shaking hands you kind of
want to be like you know I get the idea
of grabbing his hand to being like yo
explain Jar Jar Binks [ __ ] you know or
whatever whatever you would say to
George Lucas but it would be like um
that would be like amazing if you're
like a huge Star Wars follower here's
George Lucas the Godfather of this whole
thing you would want to shake his hand
you would want to do more than just
shake his hand you want you're just in
awe of that moment so I totally get that
you know what I mean you know or Mark
Hamill walks by you know I mean you want
to be like oh my god Luke I am your
father you would just all the crazy [ __ ]
that you would want to do
this is the Pope so I get this woman was
like overzealous but damn Pope you got a
beat to [ __ ] down he bliley slapped her
hand likes comment you know and he's
been doing this a lot actually cuz
there's another video of him taking
confessions not no no he wasn't taking
I'm sorry it was like I'm like after
mass type of thing if people are walking
up shaking his hand and so many people
wanted to kiss his hand and he visibly
is like pulling his hand away like nope
nope and then everybody's kinda like aha
almost gotcha
almost kissed a boat which again I
totally get if you believe in what you
believe in you think it's like the end
all be all but he's like really not I
don't think he's handling in it handling
it very diplomatically or as like the
leader of the church
he's certainly coming across like man
I'm tired of this like he wants to
retire like get me the hell out of here
I mean it's rude if you see the videos
is really funny I mean I may or may not
have the the videos on here I'm out I'm
not Rick Glassman so I don't do a lot of
edits maybe I should I don't know but
it's hard but if they are they gonna be
right there but it's just I just think
like at what point is he gonna just slap
somebody across the face like don't
touch me like enough is enough
you know or my thing is like just don't
have the meet and greets you know if you
don't want to like you don't want to
touch me you're the freakin Pope man you
know you you know you laying hands on
people people feel like they feel
blessed it is it would change their life
if you're a staunch Catholic Christian
and you are a hundred percent invest in
and what you think the Pope is and you
get to shake the Pope's hand like damn
you don't understand that that's
overwhelming for people I mean this
guy's like forgotten his position I
don't know I mean I don't know how you
feel about it you know I'm sure you'll
tell me in the comments so please go
down in the comments and let me know
what you think about that but I think
the Pope is like on his way out he might
just be like you know what [ __ ] this I'm
out all right that's the Pope let's go
to the singer might for the Pope
the Pope don't wanna touch the body